Pensemos un poco en lo que sugiere la Teoría
del Big Bang y luego, con base en esa teoría,
lo que hoy deberíamos estar observando. El Big
Bang empieza con toda la masa en el espacio, en
el universo, una singularidad infinitamente densa.
Una singularidad es algo donde las matemáticas
ni siquiera se aplican, ni siquiera sabemos cómo
entender eso. Pero inmediatamente después del Big
Bang, esto ocurrió hace 13.70 miles de millones
de años, inmediatamente después, esta singularidad
infinitamente pequeña comienza a expandirse. Los
primeros 100 mil años todavía es bastante densa,
así que vamos a visualizarlo. Empieza a
expandirse, así que imaginemos que llega a
este nivel. No sé si todo el universo es infinito
o finito, si es una esfera en cuatro dimensiones,
si va infinitamente en todas direcciones o si se
curva ligeramente por aquí y allá y el resto es
plano. No entraré en todo esto. Pero comienza a
expandirse un poco a partir de la singularidad.
Pero sigue siendo extremadamente denso, es tan
denso que los átomos ni siquiera pueden formarse,
así que sólo tienes las bases fundamentales de los
átomos: electrones y protones que están flotando
alrededor de este plasma caliente, de este plasma
ardiente, así que llamémosle plasma ardiente.
Luego avancemos un poco más en el tiempo hasta
este punto que creemos entender bien. De hecho,
investigué en algunos libros viejos de Física
y este número ha cambiado en los últimos 15,
20 años, así que tal vez cambie más, pero
después de 380,000 años desde el comienzo del
Big Bang -380 mil años a partir del Big Bang-,
y obviamente esto es más menos algunos años,
el universo se ha expandido lo suficiente.
Ahora es lo suficientemente grande,
y obviamente no estoy dibujando estas
cosas a escala, pero el universo ahora es
lo suficientemente grande y lo suficientemente
disperso como para poder enfriarse un poco, y,
por lo tanto, ya no hay tantas colisiones.
Y, claro, sigue siendo un lugar caliente,
pero ahora se ha enfriado lo suficiente como para
que un protón pueda capturar electrones, y ahora
pueden comenzar a formarse los primeros átomos
de hidrógeno, de hecho se condensan. Estimamos
que esta temperatura ronda los 3,000° Kelvin,
entonces se ha enfriado a 3,000° Kelvin, pero
ésta sigue siendo una temperatura en la que no nos
gustaría estar, es demasiado caliente. Ahora bien,
¿por qué es tan importante este momento donde
ocurre la formación de los primeros átomos? Bueno,
pensemos qué pasa por aquí: tenemos todas estas
colisiones e interacciones y, si se libera un
fotón debido a una colisión o debido a alguna
liberación de energía o debido a la temperatura
del calor, será inmediatamente absorbido por otra
cosa, si se libera algo de energía inmediatamente
será absorbida por otra cosa. Esto es debido a
que el universo es muy denso, especialmente con
partículas cargadas. Aquí, de repente, no es
tan denso. Entonces, si regresamos, las cosas
que se emitían no podían viajar largas distancias,
inmediatamente chocarían con otra cosa; mientras
que por aquí el universo comienza a parecerse
al universo que reconocemos. De repente, si uno
de estos átomos realmente caliente, y claro,
no está tan caliente como el universo de aquí,
pero si uno de estos átomos calientes emite un
fotón -y lo harán porque están a 3,000° Kelvin-,
si uno de estos átomos emite un fotón y de repente
hay espacio para que pueda viajar, entonces por
primera vez en la historia del universo, 380 mil
años después del inicio del Big Bang, tenemos
fotones, tenemos radiación electromagnética,
tenemos información que puede viajar largas,
largas distancias. Ahora bien, 380,000 años no
es mucho cuando hablamos en términos de miles
de millones de años, así que esto sigue siendo
aproximadamente 13.7 miles de millones de años;
380,000 es un número muy pequeño, realmente son
13.7 miles de millones de años menos 380,000
años. Pero dado que esta es la primera vez que
la información puede viajar, que la mayoría de
los fotones puede viajar a través del espacio
sin chocar con algo, especialmente algo que
probablemente esté cargado, la otra cosa
interesante es que estos átomos que ahora
se formaron son átomos neutros. Entonces, dado que
es la primera vez que la información puede viajar,
¿qué podemos esperar ver en la actualidad, el
día de hoy? Bueno pensamos en ello: estos fotones
fueron emitidos hace 13.7 miles de millones de
años atrás y fueron emitidos de cada punto del
universo, así que estos son cada punto en el
universo. El universo era un lugar muy uniforme
en ese momento, con muy pocas irregularidades,
pero, como podemos ver, esta cosa ardiente acaba
de comenzar a condensarse. No se ha formado
mucho de las estructuras que ahora asociamos
con el universo, en ese momento es una especie
de dispersión bastante uniforme de átomos de
hidrógeno razonablemente calientes, así que éstos
son cada punto del universo. Así que pensemos en
lo que está pasando aquí. Déjame dibujar otro
diagrama. Estamos hablando de este punto en
el universo que está justo aquí, este universo
es, incluso 380,000 años después del Big Bang,
todavía mucho, mucho, mucho, mucho más pequeño
que el universo actual. Pero digamos que este
es el punto del universo donde resulta que nos
encontramos ahora. En este momento en el tiempo no
existe la Tierra, no existe el Sistema Solar, no
existe la Vía Láctea, son sólo un montón de átomos
de hidrógeno calientes. Ahora, si estamos en este
punto del universo, deben existir otros puntos en
el universo que estén emitiendo esta radiación en
este mismo momento, y, de hecho, todos los puntos
del universo emitían esta radiación. El punto del
universo donde estamos ahora emite esta radiación,
por lo tanto, los puntos que estaban más cerca
de nosotros también emitían esta radiación,
pero nos llegó mucho antes, nos llegó hace miles
de millones de años, mientras que hay algunos
puntos que estaban lo suficientemente lejos como
para que esa radiación que emitieron la estemos
recibiendo hasta ahora. Otra forma de pensarlo
es que esta radiación ha tardado 13,700 millones
de años en llegar hasta nosotros. Es decir, si
tuviera que dibujar el universo visible actual
tendría que ser mucho, mucho más grande que este
círculo que dibujé aquí. Y ya sabes por el video
que hicimos sobre los tamaños y las escalas que
obviamente este dibujo no va a ser a escala. Pero
digamos que este es el universo visible actual
y estamos en el centro, porque siempre podemos
mirar aproximadamente a la misma distancia
en todas direcciones. Ojo, no quiere decir
que seamos el centro del universo, quiero ser
claro: somos el centro del universo observable
porque sólo podemos observar la misma distancia en
todas las direcciones, es distinto. Ahora, estamos
recibiendo algo de luz desde hace 100,000 años luz
de distancia, con ello estamos observando 100,000
años hacia el pasado; y podríamos estar recibiendo
algo de luz que se emitió por primera vez, no sé,
tal vez hace 1 millón de años luz, y eso es como
mirar 1 millón de años hacia el pasado porque la
luz que vemos se emitió hace 1 millón de años luz.
Creo que esto es un poco redundante. Podemos ver
la luz que nos llega después de viajar durante
mil millones de años, y entonces estamos mirando
estos objetos hace mil millones de años porque
fue entonces cuando emitieron la luz. Entonces,
de la misma manera, podemos mirar objetos que
emitieron su luz hace 13.7 miles de millones de
años, justo al principio, justo en esta etapa de
aquí, justo 380,000 años después del Big Bang. Y
como esa luz apenas nos está llegando, la veremos
como era hace 13.7 miles de millones de años,
por lo tanto, deberíamos de ver este tipo de
radiación. Ahora, la otra cosa que debemos
recordar es que el universo se estaba expandiendo,
cuando se emitió esta radiación el universo se
estaba expandiendo a un ritmo muy, bueno, la
velocidad de expansión es relativa y todo eso,
pero lo importante es que se estaba expandiendo.
Y como aprendimos en el video sobre corrimiento
al rojo, cuando la fuente de luz se aleja de ti o
la fuente de radiación electromagnética se aleja
de ti, la radiación en sí tiene un corrimiento al
rojo. Entonces, aunque esto tiene una frecuencia
relativamente alta, es una especie de gas al
rojo vivo a 3,000° Kelvin. Como se está alejando
de nosotros, y esto lo aprendimos en el video
sobre el tamaño actual del universo observable,
a pesar de que a estas ondas electromagnéticas
les ha tomado 13.7 miles de millones de años en
llegar a nosotros, durante ese tiempo ese punto
en el espacio, el punto en el espacio que emitió
estas ondas electromagnéticas, se alejó y ahora
está a unos 46 miles de millones de años luz de
distancia. Esa es nuestra mejor estimación; así
que esto todavía se está expandiendo. Entonces,
si crees que esto estaba a unos 3,000° Kelvin y
además que tuvo un corrimiento al rojo, la teoría
diría que no deberíamos ver algo análogo a las
ondas electromagnéticas que se liberan desde un
átomo a una temperatura de 3,000°, deberíamos ver
un corrimiento al rojo en el espectro del radio,
por lo tanto, deberíamos estar observando ondas
de radio. Y la razón por la que estamos observando
ondas de radio y no algo de una frecuencia más
alta es porque tiene un corrimiento al rojo,
hay un corrimiento al rojo hacia una frecuencia
más baja. Y recuerda: deberíamos poder ver esto
desde todos los puntos del universo donde
los fotones han viajado durante 13.7 miles
de millones de años, deberíamos verlo en todo
nuestro alrededor. Esto es casi una necesidad para
que creamos realmente en la teoría actual del Big
Bang. Y resulta que, en efecto, observamos esto;
y esto es muy poco intuitivo debido a que si
miras cualquier otro punto del universo esto no
es uniforme. En cualquier otro punto del universo
tienes estrellas y galaxias, y estos ya no son
átomos, tenemos estrellas y galaxias y cualquier
cosa, es decir, hay algunos puntos en el universo
donde ves mucha radiación y hay otros puntos en
el universo donde no ves nada, es simplemente
negro. Pero si esto es correcto, si esto sucediera
realmente, debemos poder observar ondas de radio
uniformes desde todas las direcciones a nuestro
alrededor, más de 360 grados ya que vamos en
tres dimensiones, en cualquier dirección hacia
la que apunte una antena, una antena de radio,
deben recibir estas ondas de radio que tenían una
frecuencia mucho más alta cuando se emitieron y
que después tiene un corrimiento al rojo, pero
fueron emitidas hace 13.7 miles de millones de
años. Y resulta que a finales de la década
de 1960 encontraron estas ondas de radio
en todas direcciones, y a esto le llaman la
radiación cósmica de fondo. Déjame escribirlo:
la radiación cósmica de fondo de microondas.
Entonces son estos datos que obtenemos, esta
observación en combinación con el hecho de que
cuando más miramos galaxias y cúmulos de galaxias
parecen alejarse cada vez más de nosotros,
y todo esto tiene un corrimiento al rojo,
y además se corre cada vez más y más y más al
rojo cuando más lejos miramos. Así que esto,
y todo lo que tiene un corrimiento al rojo
lejos de nosotros, son los dos mejores puntos
de evidencia de la idea actual del Big Bang. Con
suerte lo encontrarás razonablemente interesante.